Вівсяна каша, хліб, цукор і чай. Меню сніданку ще й досі висить на стінах
їдальні Ірпінського виправного центру.
Хоча самих в'язнів тут вже понад рік, як нема.
Влітку 2019 року колонію закрили як не рентабельну,
а самих в'язнів перевели до найближчих виправних центрів.
Екскурсію порожньою в'язницею для DW проводить Андрій Рог,
інженер з комунального забезпечення в'язниці.
Ви можете подивитися їхні побутвові умови.
Тут знаходилосьь 6 ліжок, тут в кожній кімнаті був телевізор.
Тут був акваріум з рибками.
А кімната навпроти - це, так би мовити, "піщовка".
Тут засудженні мали право приймати їжу,
яку вони придбали. Тут у кінці коридору знаходилась вбиральня,
а тут - рукомийники.
Це перша в'язниця, яка піде з молотка у рамках реформи
"Великий розпродаж в'язниць", до якої мін'юст готувався
майже рік. Стартова ціна в’язниці - понад 220 мільйонів гривень.
На сайті Фонду держмайна аукціон вже стартував.
Слідкуватиме за його перебігом і Андрій Рог.
Та тільки тому, що після продажу йому треба буде шукати нову роботу.
У нас за скороченням будуть іти, хто бажає піти.
Спілкуємось з іншими установами, щоб їх прийняли.
А я для себе ще не вирішив.
Останні роки роботи ця в'язниця була наповнена лише на третину.
З трьохсот чоловік, на яких розрахована колонія,
покарання відбували трохи більше ста в'язнів.
При тому, що самих працівників колонії - 80.
Ситуація, коли кількість співробітників рівна, а то й перевищувала
кількість засуджених, не поодинока.
Через це ще попередня команда мін’юсту почала закривати нерентабельні колонії.
А нинішні очільники міністерства вирішили, що 35 "законсервованих" в'язниць -
добрий актив для продажу. Виручені кошти обіцяють вкласти
в будівництво нових слідчих ізоляторів, ділиться планами
заступниця міністра юстиції Олена Висоцька.
Для нас найважливіший акцент на слідчі ізолятори,
бо там перебувають люди, які юридично ще не винні в злочині,
але при цьому для України характерно,
що там найгірші умови утримання.
Тому ми шукаємо фінансування для відбудови чи для ремонту СІЗО.
Аби ідею вдалося реалізувати мін'юст ініціював законопроєкт про зміни до Бюджетного кодексу.
Згідно з ним, 70% грошей від продажу в’язниць
має надходити на спеціальний рахунок мін'юсту,
решта 30% поповнить державний бюджет.
Утім, законопроєкт з такими поправками на початку лютого цього року
було знято з розгляду. Натомість відповідні правки внесли до Закону України
"Про державний бюджет на 2021 рік".
Але тільки про те, що 70% від продажу виправних закладів отримуватиме мін'юст.
А про те, на що саме ці гроші будуть витрачені і чи підуть вони на поліпшення
умов утримання ув'язнених, взагалі нічого не сказано.
Це дуже непокоїть громадську організацію "Україна без тортур".
Ми маємо відкриту дискусію про продаж, але вона не детальна.
Вона більше для ЗМІ, вибачте, для публікацій.
А детальний аналіз? Покроковий план дій: щодо продажів,
щодо визначення пріоритетності продажів?
У відкритому доступі я такі документи не знаходив.
Тому стриманий оптимізм від цих продажів.
А реальну оцінку давати не при продажі, а за 2-3 роки після.
Команда Костянтина Автухова регулярно відвідує місця несвободи.
Каже, що на умови утримання після переселення до інших в'язниць
засуджені не нарікають. В'язнів з Ірпінської колонії,
приміром, розподілили між сусідніми закладами,
які також були недоукомплектовані.
Натомість як була, так і залишається проблема харчування у в'язницях.
І її вирішення не потребує років підготовки, як продаж в’язниць,
нарікає громадський активіст.
Контроль за закупівлею харчів для тюрем України здійснює підпорядкована
мін’юсту установа - Генеральна дирекція Державної кримінально-виконавчої служби.
Більше того, її нині очолює чоловік заступниці міністра юстиції Олени Висоцької -
Юрій Стеценко. Згідно з розслідуванням журналістів "СлідствоІнфо",
тендери на закупівлю харчів для колоній стабільно виграють одні й ті ж компанії.
І це попри те, що деякі з них роками постачали до колоній і СІЗО
зіпсовані продукти і щодо яких ще два-три роки тому було відкрито
низку кримінальних проваджень.
Співпраця із сумнівними компаніями не припинена й досі. Цей факт,
на думку активістів, кидає тінь на нові реформи міністерства,
зокрема і на "Велику приватизацію в’язниць".
Чому ми починаємо із самих привабливих установ? Треба чесно сказати,
що Ірпінський виправний центр -  найбільш коштовне майно, яке є.
Там можна організувати будь-яку якісно нову установу.
З новим колективом, нового формату пенітенціарних установ,
така є ідея в Мін'юсті.
Ця територія дуже гарно підходить, вона поруч із столицею.
Ділянка в’язниці справді інвестиційно приваблива.
З одного боку - залізниця і лісосмуга, а з іншого - новенькі багатоповерхівки.
У мін’юсті кажуть, що, власне, через це й розраховують на жвавий аукціон.
Перебудувати ж цю колонію, наприклад, на СІЗО, по-перше, економічно не вигідно.
А по-друге, гроші треба спершу заробити.
Усі наші колонії, якщо подивитись,
може скластися враження, що, якщо вони закриватимуться,
то для того, щоб зайшов забудовник.
Все одно колонії будувалися недалеко від міста, або в місті,
і там вже є житлові будинки, квартали.
І це зіграє нам гарну користь. Ми виставляємо на прозорі аукціони,
це означає, що будуть відкриті торги і будуть ринкові умови за такі об'єкти.
Протягом двадцяти років в Україні стабільно зменшується кількість в’язнів.
Якщо на початку двотисячних їх було понад 220 тисяч,
то нині - лише п’ятдесят. Так сталося, зокрема,
і через пом’якшення кримінального законодавства.
Адже у в'язницях опинялися передусім дрібні злочинці
і скорочення кількості в’язнів відбулося насамперед у колоніях
середнього і мінімального ступеню захисту.
Натомість Колонії із суворим режимом, а також СІЗО
залишаються переповненими і потребують негайного ремонту.
За порушення прав ув’язнених в цих закладах Україна,
за рішеннями Європейського суду з прав людини,
щороку сплачує по двісті тисяч євро компенсацій.